it was less a question of if china would
retaliate but rather
how and the answer is here the u.s has
been told to close its consulate in
chengdu
raising the stakes yet further in this
diplomatic standoff
the current situation in china u.s
relations is not what china wants
and the us is completely responsible for
all of this
all of this includes the u.s imposing
sanctions on communist party officials
and companies linked to the mass
detention of uyghurs
and ordering china to shut its mission
in houston citing concerns about
espionage
the clear out is underway the president
even floated the potential to cut
diplomatic ties completely
as far as closing additional embassies
it's always possible it marks the
biggest fallout since richard nixon
renewed relations in the 70s
when he extended the hand of friendship
all the more significant then that the
u.s secretary of state would head to the
former republicans president's library
to all but declare a new cold war with
the ccp
the kind of engagement we've been
pursuing has not brought the kind of
change
inside of china that president nixon had
hoped to induce
the truth is that our policies and those
of other free nations
resurrected china's failing economy only
to see beijing bite the international
hands that were feeding it
we opened our arms to chinese citizens
only to see the chinese communist party
exploit our free
and open society back in 2017
when donald trump and xi jinping
occasionally sparred over trade
now they're even further apart it may be
a long time before they're rolling out
the red carpet for each other
again journalist
matthias berlinga is in beijing for us
matthias
how serious is this for relations
between beijing and washington
this is a retaliatory move it has been
announced from the very
beginning uh on wednesday night
uh tuesday night the u.s
ordered the the consulate in houston to
be closed and
then it was china who announced the next
day that
it had been ordered to shut it down they
have said they would retaliate everybody
was expecting they would close a
consulate
now it is clear which one it is this is
pretty much
reciprocal uh that i i would say the
the the importance of this consulate in
chengdu
is about proportionate to the consulate
in houston it is not one of the regions
where
the main economic american activities
are
but it's still very important also
because it covers
tibet um the the the
relations between the two countries are
at an all-time low
since they have established diplomatic
relations in the end of the 1970s
this move is probably not going to help
them but it is
also nothing that comes as a surprise
china has not chosen to do something
that would further escalate the
situation
an expected move but then why
specifically
the consulate in chengdu matias
the consulate in chengdu is somewhat
it is not one of the two most important
consulates
but it is still an important consulate
it covers the south west of
china that includes many
a big geographical region also a densely
populated region
people from there american citizens but
also chinese citizens who apply for
visas
will now have to travel much further
there is also a political pun
because this council was responsible
also
for covering tibet for the us and
it has some kind of it has gained some
kind of fame a few years ago
when uh the police had the head of the
the police department of
chongqing who was then
involved in a corruption scandal that
eventually
brought down the whole establishment of
this city fled to this consulate and
spent
30 hours there so this is a place that
has quite a history
matthias bilinga briefing us about that
history from beijing thank you so much